in this video I want to talk a little
bit about DNA damage specifically damage
in the form of thymine dimers and how
this is involved with xeroderma
pigmentosum so basically what happens is
imagine you have a DNA strand running
five iron and three prime point is you
have two diamonds next to each other now
if there is UV light ultraviolet light
you go out in the Sun you play out in
the Sun there's UV light that can cause
well it's called the dimerization of
these thymine nucleotides so these
diamond bases become covalently bonded
right next to each other that's not
normally supposed to happen these are
bad why are they bad they they form
these things called lesions in the DNA
so they damage the DNA structure so if
this is a DNA strand with a bunch of you
know if it has a bunch of bases like
this right they're all interacting via
hydrogen bonds that's what's holding the
DNA together and suddenly these two
things next to each other covalently
bond to each other that causes is it
causes that portion of the DNA sort of
bump off away from the DNA store from
the from the things that were
interacting with over here the a is that
they were interacting with so this thing
here is a lesion in the DNA that's bad
right you don't want your DNA to be
damaged like this so can this be fixed
the answer is yes but you must have a
particular X C nucleus enzyme so with
the Xing nucleus enzyme what that does
is it cuts out the lesion and then
eventually what can happen is the DNA
can be replaced by a DNA polymerase and
then ligase can seal the gap so
basically the DNA can be repaired so
it's not necessarily a problem but it
can be a problem in the condition called
xeroderma pigmentosum Xavier derma
pigmentosum is an autosomal recessive
genetic disorder
and that the genetic disorder it
basically it involves a lack of the
enzymes involved in repairing DNA damage
caused by this UV light so basically
with people who have xeroderma
pigmentosum they don't have the enzyme
they don't have the Xing nucleus and the
other enzymes involved in repairing
these DNA lesions caused by these
thymines dimerizes so these individuals
patients with xeroderma pigmentosum
basically if they go out in the Sun this
these lesions can form and they can't
fix that that's a problem so how are
these patients treated if the basically
the only form of treatment that they
really have there are some other forms I
think but the way these patients are
treated it basically is to avoid
exposure to UV light because DNA damage
can be severely severely bad and this is
called xeroderma pigmentosum dirham
coming from skin well they have they
have like excuse me they can potentially
get cancer of the skin and they have
lesions on their skin and if you're
curious you can conduct a Google search
but uh beware it's not the prettiest
site it can it can what's the word I'm
looking for now just be cautious when
when looking at those if you do conduct
a google image search of xeroderma
pigmentosum but i hope that you
understand the sort of molecular basis
for this right this UV light causes this
dimerization and that's a problem but it
can normally be repaired but in patients
with several different figure it's
awesome they can't repair it because
they don't have the enzymes did that
allows them to repair it so they have to
avoid exposure to UV light altogether
hope that video was helpful and clear
one last thing I am a tutor if you live
in Southern California feel free to
contact me female moof University ID
male comment see the description below
for more details thank you for watching